let's go next to our caller from the
three one five area code who's calling
today from three one five I'm David this
is Josh I see a lot of stats about
climate change and automation and I see
that they are the worst effects of them
happen to coincide around the same
decades around the 2040s and 2050 s and
I'm wondering do you think that a
liberal democracy or Western
civilization or whatever you call it i
how confident are you that these things
are going to survive
things like automation and climate
change well I think there's a bigger
question you're asking in general which
is it can feel for us right now in the
middle of it like liberal democracy and
the sort of type of geopolitical status
quo that we have is just the way things
are going to be indefinitely and then as
soon as you just zoom out a little bit
you see the impermanence of just about
everything that has existed and so my
doubts about being able to say X or Y is
going to survive beyond a particular
point is that in general we just have a
huge bias towards believing that the way
things are now are the way things are
going to remain it's very hard for us to
imagine how things could be drastically
different but you know like Rome fell
eventually and if history has taught us
anything to the extent that we know
history it's that even things that seem
permanent are not so as far as climate
change specifically there are a number
of different theories and ideas about
how quickly things are going to happen
automation etc the truth is we're pretty
damn bad as a species at predicting what
is going to be going on beyond like five
years at least societally now scientific
predictions are different things move at
a glacial pace no pun intended but even
still I don't I think that what we're
identifying now our trends and the
specificity that is sometimes attributed
is maybe a little overzealous in terms
of how good we are at predicting things
because there will be inflection points
continue to kind of like modify the
trajectory but I think with all of these
questions there are real it's it's a
serious open question as to whether
humanity will survive as we know it
beyond you know relatively modest
periods of time well I'm not worried so
much about the survival of the human
race just the I guess all the progress
we've made in the past say 200 years
yeah they're there it's completely
reasonable to think that there could be
a significant backslide there's a lot of
speculative fiction that has explored
ways in which it would happen where we
would effectively as you're saying go
back to the way things were 150 or 200
years ago and I mean I just don't know
that you know the the reason that these
questions are hard for me is like I can
just speculate but I just know that
we're terrible at this stuff at
predicting this stuff like I just don't
know I don't think we know all right
thank you all right appreciate the phone
call thank you so much